[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avez vous une idée du nombre de fois où
un individu va vivre des chocs dans sa
vie
mais vous une idée du nombre de fois où
vous vous et moi votre voisin va vivre
des chocs
émotionnels
tout au long de son existence
on peut imaginer ça fait commencer par
l'expulsion du ventre de nos mères
ça peut être la première séparation
le premier échec à l'école au travail
le premier amour aussi à je vous y prend
en train d'y penser
tous ces mini choc vont laisser des
marqueurs émotionnelle qui vont remonter
plus ou moins
un certain moment dans notre existence
il ya quelques années je suis tombé
je suis tombé tellement bas que je ne
pensais même pas que c'était possible de
toucher à ce point le fond
si aujourd'hui j'ai pris conscience que
ce parcours moore a rendu plus comme à
villiers en timo a vendu anti fragile à
cet instant précis vous vous en doutez
[Musique]
je touche le fond je ne pensais même pas
qu'il y avait des solutions des
perspectives pour rire pour rebondir et
tout mon être assez fendre
je ne suis plus rien
je n'ai plus d'autre choix
que de faire
une introspection et de comprendre
pourquoi un j'en suis arrivée là qu'est
ce qui s'est passé j'ai eu une carrière
brillante un parcours parfait sur le
papier et pourquoi là à cet instant je
m'effondre
alors je réalise
que ce n'est pas la première fois que je
vis ça
que j'ai déjà vécu des lignes choc même
si celui ci est d'une violence extrême
et que j'ai déjà vécu ça à travers le
parcours de mes parents lorsque j'étais
enfant
mon père et ma mère former un couple
mixte qui n'était pas à la mode dans les
années 70 80
ils ont
eu énormément de de départ à zéro
beaucoup de réussite et beaucoup d'amour
dans le cockpit est fort mais beaucoup
départ à zéro aussi à cause d'erreurs
d'investissement non pair des erreurs de
jugement les routes a aussi eu des
grèves à madagascar où on est obligé de
fuir la famine
oui j'avais déjà vécu ça je me souviens
de certaines soirées enfants où on
n'allait rien à manger rien et alors ma
mère avec beaucoup d'amour cuisiner
du riz avec de l'eau le versus ou que
vous connaissez peut-être
un plat avec à base d'oignons à
l'indienne
je me souviens aussi des langoustes
grillées comme angers à la plage quand
mon père voulait célébrer ses victoires
ou juste mettre en place des moments de
partage plus parce qu'on s'est parlé
beaucoup parce qu'on était ensemble
alors nous étions une fratrie de 11
enfants aux enfants j'ai arrêté de
compter après un enfant vous vous en
doutez
c'est dur de trouver sa place
j'ai été considéré comme une enfant
insignifiante transparente quasi
inexistante
mais il ne se passait pas une seule
journée où je ne grimpe et pas une seule
église dont celui de sheila vous ce
manque et
pour grandir plus vite me réfugier au
silence un jardin secret voir loin et à
ce moment là tout était possible je ré
vide de plein de choses
je rêvais que ça pouvait être autrement
alors il y avait beaucoup d'amour dans
notre famille aussi imparfaite qu'elle
soit
et aujourd'hui je prends la pleine
mesure de toutes les valeurs qui m'ont
été transmises
quelles sont les valeurs que vous allez
reçu dans vos à vérité que vous avez
peut-être parfois aussi refoulé
en fonction de votre parcours de vie que
je respecte quelles sont les valeurs qui
font ce que vous êtes aujourd'hui une
partie de ce que vous êtes aujourd'hui
qui sont votre socle vos fondations
alors il ya cet instant où nous arrivons
à dos lorsque j'étais adolescente en
europe
hélas il si le choc
je prends une véritable claque je prends
conscience que ça veut dire la
différence
je réalise à cet instant précis qu'on
pouvait déranger juste à cause de notre
couleur de peau je prends conscience à
cet instant précis qu'on pouvait
déranger juste parce qu'on respire l
inverse que d'autres personnes il s'agit
pas juste une lutte pour notre survie il
s'agit d'une lutte pour trouver sa place
dans un système qui n'a pas besoin de
vous et qui nous attendait pas
je mets en place des mécanismes de sueur
adaptation je me fonds dans la base je
rentre dans le moule
et jeudi une partie de mes origines dans
l'espoir de pouvoir prendre ma place
j'ai eu la chance de beaucoup voyager
j'ai la chance d'avoir une carrière
extraordinaire qui va amener au contact
de nombreuses cultures
et là c'est le même constat
j'ai rencontré des personnes formidables
avec qui j'ai pu collaborer
mais à chaque fois je réalise que c'est
toujours un champ relationnel à sens
unique et que je suis amené à m'adapter
voir à mesures adaptées
on me demande de parler allemand pour
travailler avec des allemands en me
demande de comprendre l'espagnol pour
travailler dans l'environnement
hispaniques et je suis extrêmement
frustré de ne pas comprendre le contenu
ou le mandarin pour travailler avec la
chine et autant vous dire que pour moi
le cantonais c'est du chinois
là aussi je mesure à quel point notre
cerveau et claniques et qu'il a besoin
de mettre chacun chaque individu chaque
émotion
chaque événement dans une case
et qui va rejeter ce qu'il ne lui
apparaît pas
rentrer dans cette case dans ce moule
dans cette norme
notre cerveau serait-il donc
communautariste
je regrette dans ce champ relationnel
unis que
que chacun d'entre nous oublient une
chose fondamentale c'est que nous sommes
orientés survie notre cerveau est
orienté survie nous sommes tous orientés
vers un but commun qui est la survie de
notre espèce et l'évolution de notre
humanité
et que nous avons toutes et tous ont
cette compétence
ce langage est universel qu'est
l'intelligence du coeur
alors à cet instant précis où je
m'effondre vous l'aurez compris
je réalise que je n'ai mas place nulle
part et qu'il faut donc pouvoir
trouver leur place
la multiculturalité que je perçois comme
un handicap social devient des plus
grandes richesses
mais oui
puisque genève à place nulle part et que
cette multiculturalité l'a finalement
mon m'empêche me contraint à choisir
je n'ai plus d'autre choix que de me
détacher de la notion de culture pour
pouvoir
rencontrer ma véritable nature à cet
instant précis où je m'effondre où je ne
suis plus rien
ou je n'existe plus à cet instant précis
je vais à la rencontre de mon véritable
être et je prends conscience de tout ce
qui s'est joué tous ses schémas de
répétition de tous ces conditionnements
familiaux intergénérationnel
transgénérationnel
je vous la fait courte mais dans ma
mémoire il y a mémoires d'exil
loin de l'afrique
une mémoire
des migrations une mémoire de kate de
places mémoire de regel les voir
d'injustice une mémoire de perdre au
rang social et moi vos réussites
sociales
alors moi qui étais convaincu dans la
toute puissance et gothique que j'avais
écrit ma propre histoire que j'allais
transcender mon histoire que j'étais
allé au-delà
de ce qui arrive plus de deux pistes et
conditionnement enfants je ne faisait
que répéter les chambres et cet instant
où je m'effondre même si cet
effondrement là n'est qu'une répétition
de ce que je connaissais déjà j'étais en
totale loyauté avec tous mes conditions
quelle claque
la multiculturalité
aujourd'hui si celle qui m'aura sauvé la
vie
cette multiculturalité ces trois jambes
que je percevais comme un handicap
elle me rend sauvé la vie elle me rend
permise de me réveiller et surtout de
révéler de me reconnecter à cette petite
fille qui rêvait lancement billets ou
dans ce métier et qui rêvait d'un
autrement qui rêvait d'écrire sa propre
histoire
toute l'ailé tout ce que j'avais
construit jusque là en fait n'était que
qu'une prison dorée qui m'éloigne est de
plus en plus de la liberté qui était
crucial pour m'assurer
la liberté à 11 ans qu'est ce que la
liberté en fonction des cultures elle va
être perçue différemment en fonction de
vos parcours de vie elle va être perçue
différemment
qu'est ce que la liberté pour voir ce
que c'est la liberté intellectuelle est
ce que c'est la liberté
affective
est ce que c'est la liberté financière
est ce que la crise en doré que vous
vous construisez depuis tant d'années
c'est ça la liberté
et puis le temps aussi j'y passais tout
une partie de ma vie à courir après le
temps et je courais en permanence
jusqu'à cet effondrement où je réalise
que je que je ne savais même pas après
quoi je courrai
le temps l'espace temps va différentes
va différer aussi en fonction des
cultures en afrique on a plutôt la
culture d'humour amoureux
on va être plutôt dans l'instant dans
l'immédiateté dans la semaine sur l'île
mais on va aussi loué un véritable culte
aux ancêtres que l'on respecte
énormément
en asie notamment en inde
on va rencontrer également ce cette
connexion aux traditions ancestrales
mais aussi à cet instinct de survie
et puis la culture occidentale dans
laquelle j'ai évolué toute une partie de
ma vie
on va être dans une véritable
accélération du temps on va courir après
le temps
et je sais pas si vous l'avez remarqué
mais
vous êtes en train de faire quelque
chose que vous êtes déjà en train de
penser à
l'action d'après grève n'est plus là
vous êtes déjà
tourné vers le futur
ce que l'on va aujourd'hui pouvoir
rencontrer dans la pleine conscience
dans les cultures asiatiques notamment
et qui sont qui sont des pépites
pour pouvoir se reconnecter à l'être
alors je prend pleinement conscience
effectivement de ces répétitions de
schéma à mon échelle à l'échelle
individuelle elle ça se joue
probablement aussi pour vous hein et
puis à l'échelle collective notre
cerveau étant clanique et ont orienté
survie en fait il ne dit pas ce sens
tant collectivement à maintenir les
schémas pour préserver le clan la
communauté la case
napoléon il
disait que nous avions souvent peur de
nos idées nouvelles que l'on percevait
comme dangereuse oui oui on va les
percevoir comme dangereuse parce que
vous l'auriez compris notre cerveau
fonctionne
par répétition de schéma il ne l est
programmé pour refaire ce qu'il connaît
déjà c'est un peu vous savez comme cette
touche raccourci sur l'ordinateur
et va fonctionner par économie d'énergie
dont salah nous prendre de l'énergie de
faire autrement de construire une
histoire qui puisse être différente de
celle pour laquelle nous avons été
conditionnés
alors par survie ou ce que l'on croit
par survie immédiate à l'instant t on va
reproduire des mécanismes que l'on
connaît déjà
c'est notre fameuse zone de confort
alors oui on a un pouvoir créateur
aujourd'hui à l'intérieur de soi oui on
a une puissance créative on pourrait
faire autrement mais à quel moment on va
s'autoriser à se détacher de toutes ces
croyances de tous ces conditionnements
millénaire vous pouvoir oser
écoutez cette partie à l'intérieur de
soi qui rêvent d'un autrement
peut-être que vous êtes ce petit garçon
enfermé dans son placard et qui se
mettait à rêver d'un autrement
peut-être que vous êtes cette petite
fille
dans cet art
au web
dans ce lit le soir à rêver d'un
autrement
à quel moment est ce que vous allez
laisser de l'espace à cet enfant à
l'intérieur de vous qui a envie d'écrire
son histoire autrement sans répéter le
schéma
à quel moment vous allez vous autoriser
à vous détacher
de l'instinct de survie pour vraiment
réellement vivre votre vie
à quel moment est-ce que vous allez vous
autoriser à vous détacher de cette
injonction
de survie de l'espèce claniques pour
pouvoir créer
un univers
qui vous ressemble